here at home new concerns over inflation
led wall street stocks to have their
worst day in two years a huge selloff
yesterday erased all of the gains from
wednesday the market's best day since
2020. all the major indexes made big up
and down moves after the federal reserve
raised interest rates by half a
percentage point to fight inflation cbs
news business analyst jill schlesinger
is here and i'm glad she's here because
we have a lot of questions to jump right
into it so the stocks jumped wednesday
um after the announcement and then
yesterday why the huge sell-off i think
that what happened at the fed meeting
day was that people said oh the fed's
not going to raise rates by 0.75 it's
just going to be 0.5 and they kind of
got excited and happy about that drove
stocks higher that's why i said
yesterday morning check your 401ks this
morning but yesterday after more thought
i think the same issue remains can the
fed raise interest rates by enough to
kind of clamp down on inflation without
throwing the economy into a recession
and that's the big question and that's
making people nuts right now it's been a
rough year for the stock market even
before yesterday so what do people do
with their money out now are there safe
places to invest okay couple of things
number one take a deep breath if you're
a long time don't panic yeah well i mean
you can panic but you gotta calm
yourself down okay because we don't want
you to act if you're a long-term
investor this is actually not bad news
you're going to put new money in you're
going to buy shares at lower levels
things are on discount 10 to 20 from
from the beginning of the year however
if you need your money within the next
year you've got to make sure it's safe
it cannot be at risk maybe you made a
mistake you had too much at risk you got
to get that money out and you want to
put it in someplace safe so you're
talking about those that are thinking
about retiring or maybe sending the kids
to school let's just think of it two
ways one is if i'm about to retire i may
not want to go to cash because my
money's got to last me 20 30 years but
if i need to write a tuition check i've
got to get that money out of risky
assets put in something safe what's safe
a checking a savings a money market you
get the best rates by using an online
institution if you don't need your money
for one to five years i encourage people
to go check out the government savings
bonds that are linked to inflation eye
bonds on monday the treasury department
announced that i bonds can be purchased
with a 9.62
guaranteed interest rate you can buy 10
000 guaranteed my friend by uncle sam
and by the way you can buy 10 000
per calendar year so check it out
treasurydirect.gov i love it when you
join us dollar dollar jill y'all thank
you so much